for nearly a year now fans of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe have been trying to
puzzle out where the story is going in
the aftermath of Avengers infinity war
but now a new special look trailer has
arrived for Avengers endgame the
franchise's 22nd movie on the very same
morning that tickets for the movie went
on sale barely a minute long
the teaser provides some of the most
thrilling and substantial endgame
footage we've seen yet want to know how
the trailer might clue us into what
actually happens in the movie here's a
potentially spoiler filled look at the
small details you may have missed in the
special look trailer for Avengers and
game everyone knows endgame is revving
up for a rematch between the Avengers
and Thanos a grudge match which the new
trailer seems to explicitly show but
what if that rematch happens sooner than
we think it's very likely a mix of
rumors and reports indicate that the
marketing for Avengers endgame features
footage from only the first 15 or 20
minutes of the movie keeping the secrets
of its story held close to the vest
until the movie has rolled out in
theaters while the 15 to 20 minute
window that's been reported doesn't seem
exactly right Marvel Studios head Kevin
Feige has said in an interview with MTV
News that those reports are still
somewhat accurate if he's being truthful
and implies that the trailer footage of
the Avengers facing off against Thanos
again won't come at the end of the movie
but instead somewhere in the first act
this theory tracks with multiple
purported leaks from the movie that
acclaim the Avengers will team up to
fight Thanos in space somewhere in the
beginning of endgame it's possible that
the team will even defeat him in this
battle but in a way that prevents the
Fallen from being revived if it feels
wild to you consider that infinity war
kicked off with Hulk fighting Thanos
within the first 5 minutes of the film
so if you think it's unlikely that this
movie will hit the ground running with
its plot think again these are going to
be three dense hours one of the biggest
rumors that's been swirling about
avengers endgame is that it will feature
a significant jump forward in time with
some reports claiming the whole movie
will be set five years after infinity
war the trailers have finally given us
enough footage to assume that a time
jump will indeed a curb but in the
middle of the movie rather than before
it begins the biggest clue about when
the Avengers are at any given point is
the hairs
I love Natasha aka Black Widow an
infinity war she memorably sports a
blonde Bob presumably to work incognito
as a member of caps Secret Avengers the
trailers for endgame have shown the
character with both that same blonde
hairdo but also a return to her longer
red haired style similar to what she
wore in previous movies in the new
trailer Natasha can be seen in her
infinity war haircuts in the Guardians
Benatar ship presumably on the way to
fight Thanos somewhere in space an act
which seems to be predicted by Bruce
banners line if we do this we'd be going
in short-handed that freezing seems to
imply that the Avengers will take the
fight to Thanos where he is wherever he
is at the end of infinity war Thanos
retired to a peaceful life on a farm on
a planet the Russo brothers have called
titan' to the special.look trailer seems
like it might show The Avengers
encountering him back on the first Titan
in the still smoldering rubble left
behind from their first encounter with
him whatever happens in this fight it
seems like it won't result in the
revival of the people fan o snapped away
after the snap an infinity war theosis
gauntlet was left smoldering and damaged
potentially leaving him vulnerable to
attack especially if the team now has
Captain Marvel on their side
[Music]
I like this one if they actually do kill
thanos then it makes sense why the
Avengers and the world would begin to
move on with their lives afterward which
is what seems to be happening in the
previously released Super Bowl teaser
which showed many shots of an abandoned
and neglected world but this status quo
would be disrupted by the return of
Scott Lang's ant-man who was seen in the
second trailer roaming around a world
well after the snap a vamp man
approaches the Avengers with his new
knowledge of time travel it could lead
the team to reunite for a full victory
not just beating Thanos but keeping him
from ever killing the trillions of
people he did in infinity war apart from
all the time travel time skip rematch
shenanigans the new footage also shows a
remarkably touching moment between two
characters the relevance of which may
have slipped by some viewers the first
trailer for endgame saw Tony and nebula
adrift in space on the now abandoned
Benatar and the special look teaser
seems to show the moment the two will
arrive back on earth with Tony being
embraced by Pepper Potts and nebula
getting her bearings as she lands on
earth for the first time while Rocket
saw a group fall away into dust at the
end of Avengers infinity war he has no
knowledge whatsoever regarding the fate
of the rest of his team for all he knows
when he sees the Benatar screaming into
the Earth's atmosphere for a landing
it's the rest of his team coming back
ready to pick him up and get out of
there
so imagine his surprise when he sees
nebula and only nebula instead this
moment of these two former enemies
offering each other some comforts is
more than likely the moment rocket
realizes that he's lost everyone to
Thanos and it's probably not long before
these two outer space
outcasts decide to suit up as Avengers
instead fans have known for quite a
while that the production of Avengers
endgame involved a recreation of set
pieces from past movies in the MCU
specifically the Battle of New York
against Thanos his army of shatori that
wrapped up the end of the first Avengers
movie leaked set photos on the main
culprit for why so many fans figure
endgame will center on time-travel but
the latest trailer seems to show some
footage of the Avengers actually working
in the past during the special look spot
there's a brief moment that shows Iron
Man soaring through the sky and what
to be New York City with a clip looking
like it could have come straight out of
the first Avengers if anything it's
certainly a much sunnier look at the
city than the rest of endgames marketing
has shown so far so is this a shot of
future Toney soaring through past New
York working on some plan to get the
space stone out of the tesseract before
Loki can even begin the invasion it
seems possible and even likely that this
shot is one of our first looks at the
end games tour through Marvel movies
past with this final movie of phase 3
the relationship between Iron Man and
Captain America seems to finally be
coming full circle just check out this
huge moment you trust me and - and that
looks like more than just a handshake it
looks like it could be a moment that
signifies the official repair of their
relationship this is something we've
been waiting for since the end of
Captain America's Civil War a handshake
three years in the making
one question that remains is just which
Tony and Steve this is if this encounter
takes place while the Avengers are
traveling through time then it's
possible that this meetup is of present
Tony and a past version of Steve or vice
versa it's hard to tell but it is
interesting to note that Steve is
wearing what looks like his outfit from
infinity war but without the beard
potentially implying that this is indeed
a cap post infinity war if that's the
case then this clip really does show our
heroes making good after all these years
back on each other's side to face
Thanos's ultimate threat check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Avengers
and gamer coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]